why we are giving up on the film
industry it sounds extreme but wait
there's good news here at first we're
gonna tell you a story we're gonna tell
you a story about what we learned trying
to make a movie in the system and then
we're going to tell you what we're doing
about it so you might remember two years
ago we filmed the video in here talking
about the beast as a script we had just
finished very super excited to make it
into a movie heck you might remember us
a few years back talking about tether
before that another thing we had
finished we're super excited to make it
in the movie like you know what we're
corridor digital yeah people like our
stuff let's go out there and let's do it
here we come we're gonna talk to
producers we're gonna make it happen
oh let's show Hollywood that we have
what it takes to make a movie we can do
it boy how naive we were know I'm kind
of sad not bad sad we have a big
announcement coming we have an idea
let's tell you a little story
we've done some long-form projects in
the past rush fun to make totally marred
though with just the system the entire
way through first off we wrote it as a
feature film halfway through we're
starting to get notes from these
executives saying hey actually we're
gonna be wanting to turn this into a
like a web series now and so we're like
what are we shooting
not to mention EA gives us the rights
that the game battlefield before filming
it so they're like you can use
battlefield but it has to be based on
battlefield hardline which is our police
based game and we're like oh okay and
this we write a treatment for that and
then they're like actually hold on we
don't really care anymore and so we
write it about normal battlefield and
then at the end of the project we've
wrapped and then they're like also you
don't have the rights because of that
the budget is like basically being
reduced because we can't advertise it as
battlefield so rush came out as I can go
90 so you had to go to some arbitrary
Verizon platform they can only watch on
your phone to watch our series until
melee there's a barrier to watching it
once again these are products of the
system products of this big old-school
executive system that runs a lot of big
creative content you see go 90 YouTube
read tombstones kwibi
lifeline same situation you know it's
like hey we're gonna make a show with
YouTube creators and then they're like
so we're gonna have you go into casting
sessions for like two months straight
and at the end of it we're just gonna
say actually we're casting it now and
we're like okay cast it and then boom
you meet the actor first time on set
great who are you I don't know you're
this character it's like okay is this
character like a happy or angry and we
can in between and it's kind of
complicated there's elements I was proud
of during those experiences a lot of
learning for sure but ultimately each
one was a like alright let's perform the
craziest like mental acrobats we can to
navigate this like political TV
executive system it's all just so we can
get some dang funding to try to make
some cool stuff there's a realization
that going into the traditional
Hollywood system just might not be
something that happens for us at least
in the route that you're supposed
supposed to do it it will we make
something cool down the line well stay
tuned to the end of the video for the
answer to that we're getting closer to
work to the announcement we're not there
so few more things to say back there
that's me now so don't look at so how
close hurry had making the Beast well we
finished the script is great and made
all this revisions is shiny polished we
sent it off to some producers and we got
a great response not only did they like
the script but they you know saw the
YouTube channel they're really impressed
and we got our first meeting it was a
big producer we're gonna make this you
know big budget movie it always seems
like such a great situation going in but
coming out of it it's always the same
result we had you know I just put
together all kind of stuff and the
producer pulled us into a serious
meeting we had to put another producer
who was very serious same things like
your stuff loved the script I really
want to make a movie with you and really
great yeah wow this is the closest we've
ever been like real for real it's like
it's an original script in the hands of
someone who actually is passionately
about
he's like keeping us timelines I'm going
to shoot it and we're like whoa this is
this is very real oh wait what's that
let's set up the giant bu T floating
down a big ol what is that
[Laughter]
but actually let's rewrite your script
from the ground up to fit a really
conventional horror movie that we can
sell internationally and then we also
want to make sure that you guys have
about half the money that we discussed
making it for we're like well okay so
basically what you're asking for us to
do is for us to basically leave the
YouTube channel for one to two years
maybe get a shot at having a successful
film is this just a notch on our belt at
this point like this isn't even
sustainable it's like we'll make a movie
maybe it popped out and became a big
horror film and yeah and I started doing
the math on it and I broke the budget
down there offering I'm like wait a
second like if you added up all the last
corridor videos we did it's like the
same budget we're basically working it
right now the only difference is that we
would make it and we wouldn't own it and
there's no way like you guys would
really be able to get anything out of it
because we can't release it on YouTube
we can't show it to the people who
really want to see it first the
economics of this don't really add up
anymore it came down to this fork in the
road on one hand this opportunity to do
a film it wasn't gonna be on our terms
we're gonna own it in the other path is
find a system and create a system to be
able to do this ourselves because that
itch isn't going away this is a big
announcement here hearsay at the same
time ready 3 2 1 go this is super cool
look this is not just about what we want
to make it's also about what you want to
watch imagine we release the video and
you really like it and you leave a
comment saying you want to see more of
it or want to see a bigger version of it
or something like that now imagine if
each of those comments actually
financially contributed we could made 10
tethers by now exactly and I feel like
that's that's the spark that we want to
keep here we want to be able to create
things that you really want to see and
then make sure that your voice is heard
it sounds really corporate when you say
it your voice oh yo you've got the power
but the thing is is that this is kind of
a story about systems here like the
YouTube system that's one of them the
film industry that's another one and
then what we're creating is something
that's different from both we're gonna
make you the executive I'm going to be
doing a subscription-based website
you're going to be getting a
representation of what your subscription
is and then you can decide what shows
your subscription goes to we're not just
launching it by the way we have shows we
have ideas
they're coming you'll see you soon you
will be able to be the audience for the
shows that you want to see you don't
have to wait for some majority audience
to hopefully like something that you
like you just get to see it yourself the
great thing about the system is that it
eliminates us having to go out and try
to find financing from some arbitrary
person be it eliminates the wonkiness
and the Kickstarter system where you're
trying to just fund something but then
you don't know what to do with it cuz
you don't know your way to distribute it
and see it builds up a relationship
between you and the arts you want to see
so we will be launching the website soon
there are a few weeks away we are
working on finishing it right now but in
the meantime thank you for watching our
stuff and for inspiring us because it's
with your passion for our content that
we have realized that the Hollywood
system is not where we want to be we
want to be here with you and this Web
site is a way for us to do this together
so we'll be talking more about it soon
we'll be announcing it soon thank you
for hearing us out in this video
corridor digital comm is going to be
really cool well what was that sorry
what did I say it's the upside the web
saying subscribe is gonna have a whole
new meaning in a matter of weeks here